pis la conduite hébreu tenait ce mot il
sera dans l'avenir aussi familiers que
celui de moteur est clos il avait raison
ce journaliste en 1965 53 ans plus tard
on en parle plus que jamais depuis
septembre un train équipé d'une pile à
combustible circulent en allemagne une
première ce trail français construit par
alstom et il remplacera l'avenir les
locomotives diesel et polluantes qui
roule sur le réseau non électrifiées une
alternative écologique déjà vanté 1966 à
sailly et pour ne pas dire agressés par
les décibels plongé dans une atmosphère
qui attaquent en certains points de
certaines villes la limite de pollution
admissible l'homme de la civilisation du
moteur est aujourd'hui sérieusement
menacée dans son équipe
écoutons l'ingénieur grégoire on peut
imaginer surtout dans les villes des
voitures électriques qui ne
fonctionnerait pas avec des
accumulateurs avec le combustible et de
l'hydrogène comme l'expliquent ce
chercheur sur son tableau le gaz combiné
à de l'oxygène fournit de l'électricité
la pile à combustible c'est une petite
centrale qui alimente un moteur
électrique
la technologie est balbutiante mais ça
fonctionne cette pile fonctionne et
voyez vous si on la met en marche et
bien cette petite hélice se met à
tourner elle tournait la source
d'alimentation électrique est exactement
la même que celle qui fait fonctionner
tous les appareils de bord sur la gamine
gemini gemini la capsule spatiale
américaine qui a embarqué une pile à
combustible en 65 mais ça marche aussi
sur terre en plus petit
leurs applications sont multiples
pourquoi pas demain à l'automobile
puisqu'il existe déjà une pile capable
d'actionner une hélice de bateau ou de
mettre en rotation une roue il est
aujourd'hui dépassé le temps où les
piles à combustible se bornait à faire
fonctionner les petits trains
électriques des ingénieurs il faudra
quand même attendre avant de passer du
jouet au train grandeur nature en 1965
ce chercheur s'est un peu emballé
je craque vers 1970 vous pourrez aussi
avec une voiture appuyé le combinant la
technologie coûte très cher et les
encombrantes avec des rendements faibles
plus de trente ans plus tard regarder
cette laguna break
la pile prend toute la place à l'arrière
mais ça roule les expérimentations se
multiplient comme en islande
c'est l'euphorie la pile à combustible
ça ne dégagent que de la vapeur d'eau
en fait je ne recommande pas
particulièrement mais ça peut se boire
en 2015 des taxis à hydrogène circulent
dans paris et une station est
spécialement inauguré pour eux reste un
problème l'hydrogène il faut le produire
et pour le produire il faut de l'énergie
du pétrole du gaz ou du charbon
l'argument écolo tombe à l'eau à moins
que dans les années 70 cet homme
produisait de l'hydrogène avec de
l'énergie solaire et ça fonctionne
[Musique]